everybody's here we're just hanging out
making troubles post Malone denying
rumors of drug abuse and addressing
comments about his recent weight loss
the rapper Who's noticeably shed some
lbs lately assures fans he's not doing
drugs I'm having a lot of fun performing
and have never felt healthier music you
know brings it all together and makes it
you know just one whole Malone admits
he's had a lot of people ask me about my
weight loss his explanation I guess Dad
life kicked in yeah the 27 year old
singer welcomed a daughter last year
with his fiancee whom he's chosen to
keep out of the spotlight it's a lot of
pressure you know there's you know I'm
kind of a shy guy and now he's focused
on a healthier lifestyle like eating
better and giving up soda so he can be
around for a long time for his child
well it seems like a new chapter for
Malone fans will recall made headlines
in 2018 for reportedly spending forty
thousand dollars on food deliveries in
just over one year is it true that you
really were the leading Postmates person
in the whole country I'm sure I mean the
way that we use it we use it for
everything we order a bunch of these we
order a bunch of wine bunch of a bunch
of other fun goodies and I'm sure I use
it twice a day the health update comes
as Malone is on tour overseas where in
between performances he's also back in
the studio working on new music
his message to fans thank you for your
patience and support you make my
heartbeat I'm here to make
music that will stand the test of time
and that everybody can come together and
just love each other too and just have
fun too and everybody you know just
turns up to it when it comes to Malone's
focus on health he says up next he's
cutting back on smoking and drinking but
he says he's taking it one step at a
time joking I like to consider myself a
patient man
[Music]
foreign